Декілька потужних вибухів серед білого дня - ці відео облетіли соцмережі.
Вони зняті в курортній Новофедорівці, неподалік Євпаторії, в анексованому Росією Криму.
Місцеві та відпочивальники так описують те, що сталося.
Я буквально вийшла з машини, пішла руки помити, і чую - земля пішла. Я стою, і здається, що я чи злетіла, чи пішла вниз. Це було так страшно.
Таке враження, як від ядерного грибка. Такий грибок піднімався. Таких було два вибухи. Все почало падати довкола, валитися.
За словами очевидців, вибухи відчувалися за кілька кілометрів від епіцентру.
Струс надпотужний. Будинок аж здригнувся, шибки полетіли, дружину накрило. Повибивало раму. Я, чесно кажучи, не зрозумів, що там відбувається.
Але слава Богу, всім сказав: "На підлогу! І повзіть у ванну". Пролунали чергові вибухи, такі потужні вже втретє.
Місцева адміністрація повідомляє про одного загиблого та 14 постраждалих, а також про пошкодження понад 60 багатоквартирних будинків.
2014-го Росія незаконно анексувала Крим. Президент Зеленський у своєму зверненні наголосив, що півострів прямо пов'язаний із нинішньою війною.
Ця російська війна проти України та проти всієї вільної Європи почалася з Криму і має закінчитися Кримом. Його визволенням.
Сьогодні не можна сказати, коли це станеться, але ми постійно додаємо необхідні компоненти до формули звільнення Криму.
Міноборони Росії заявило про детонації на майданчику для зберігання боєприпасів.
Вибухи, за словами відомства, не були результатом обстрілу, а пов'язані з порушеннями правил пожежної безпеки.
Київ свою причетність до події офіційно заперечує.
При цьому радник офісу Зеленського Михайло Подоляк припустив, що до вибухів могли бути причетні місцеві партизани.
Водночас у ЗСУ повідомили про знищення на військовому аеродромі Саки дев'яти російських літаків,
при цьому погоджуючись із російською версією про спалах.
Досі Україна офіційно не проводила жодної наступальної операції в Криму, а лише загрожувала ударами по кримському мосту.
Проте закордонні експерти схиляються до того, що удару завдали українці.
Звісно, це були українці. Ми вже чули це раніше від росіян. Ви, напевно, пам'ятаєте, коли затонув крейсер "Москва", теж розповідали подібні історії.
А насправді, як згодом з'ясувалося, це українці вразили його ракетою.
Причина, чому українці трохи висловлюються неоднозначно - може, це ми, а може, і не ми - оскільки це сіє замішання та страх серед росіян.
Особливо у російських військових, дислокованих у Криму.
Спостерігачі звертають увагу на те, що українські війська знаходяться за 200 кілометрів від місця вибуху.
І, за наявною інформацією, українська армія поки не має у своєму розпорядженні ракет такої дальності дії.
Тим не менше, New York Times також виходить з того, що вибухи були результатом української атаки.
Видання та інші експерти припускають, що ЗСУ застосували зброю, розроблену в самій Україні.
У свою чергу, російська сторона не може звинуватити Україну в ракетному ударі по аеродрому Саки в Криму,
оскільки це продемонструвало б неефективність російської системи ППО, вважають європейські та американські аналітики.
Я думаю, це продовження колишньої стратегії. Адже ударом по Криму українці дають зрозуміти росіянам,
що ніде на окупованій українській території не є безпечно. А для росіян Крим - це найважливіша територія, яку захоплено.
Важливіша, ніж Донбас.
Очевидно, що Росія не хоче визнавати, що Україна може завдавати таких ударів чи здійснювати такі диверсії так глибоко на території,
яку Росія вважає своєю і вважає безпечною для своїх громадян.
Тобто це дуже важливий суттєвий момент, оскільки Крим - це місце, куди Росія закликає своїх громадян їхати відпочивати.
Визнати, що це небезпечне місце означає "вбити" курортний сезон, означає завдати дуже серйозної шкоди іміджу Криму
як саме курортного регіону, над яким Росія працювала багато років, куди вкладалися гроші.
Тому я припускаю, що вони робитимуть усе, щоб й надалі говорити, що Крим - це безпечно, їдьте туди відпочивати,
але ми бачимо зараз черги на виїзд з Криму, і невідомо, як довго ця тенденція продовжиться.
Чи повернуться ті, хто виїхав чи ні, чи поїдуть нові люди?
Іміджева втрата для Росії, звичайно, була б надзвичайно велика.
Набагато більша, ніж втрата кількох літаків, які там згоріли очевидно на військовому летовищі.
Саме психологічний ефект цього удару для українців, психологічний ефект для Росії та західних партнерів
- його дуже важко оцінити. Таких випадків просто ще не було за цих пів року і значна частина українців,
судячи з реакції у соцмережах, чекала побачити ці кадри 8 років.
Навіть не пів року від початку активної агресії, а 8 років відколи почалася анексія Криму.
На думку оглядачів, у випадку з вибухами в Криму, як і з затонулим російським крейсером "Москва",
Росія буде й надалі заперечувати український слід.